gq magazine says there's a post pandemic
tattoo boom
so today we've got a mom joining us she
recently became an empty nester
to jonathan and thomas and
she wants to show her kids a little love
with some body art
i actually have my daughter's names
tattooed on my wrist but i felt like
it wasn't enough i've been wanting to
scratch that
itch and so guess what i'm joining
christine today
and we're both getting tattoos right
here
right now and today will be a day that
we will
never forget and
the coolest thing is we are also going
to hang out with
none other than the very first woman
to win inkmaster it's ryan ashley
so christine and i will be your loyal
humble subjects today ryan
christine what are you getting today and
what's the significance of it
true i'm so excited to be here first of
all and
i am getting a sun and moon tattoo i'm
recently divorced
so um i'm up for new beginnings and i've
been talking about it forever
and when the pandemic hit i wasn't able
to do it i'm so
excited to be a part of this moment i am
so excited to be a part of this moment
with
everyone here it's incredible
i hope it's okay that i cut in on your
dance
with ryan i thought we could create a
triangle
of a day that all of us will never
forget i mean ryan
you are when i talk about you people
freak out because you are such a
superstar in the tattoo world you
lead seminars you are the first female
to win ink masters you have spin-off
shows i mean you're the one
oh my gosh that is it's crazy hearing
that because i also
you know became a new mom very recently
and i will say
it is the hardest job i've had so far so
this is an incredible experience i am so
excited for you christine and excited to
be here and i think it's going to be
something really really incredible
a mother's day uh that none of us will
ever forget
and we'll check in throughout the show
christine you'll be getting your tattoo
we're going to do ours at the news desk
which i thought was really fun
so let's get started how's it going
ladies
i'm going to have to say usually when
people sit this well for their first
tattoo
they don't stick with one i'm just gonna
put that out
interesting interesting and christine
can you describe the feeling of your
very first
tattoo it's a piece of cake drew you're
getting a tattoo on television
i am i'm so excited for you i can't wait
to see what you're getting
i am so excited i came up with this
phrase
and i've been saying it to myself for
the last five years
what is it it's home is where we are
oh you know if you're somewhere on
vacation
or you're in a rental or you're in
transition
or you have to move from one state to
the next
if you're together that's where home is
i could not love that
more that's amazing okay christine are
you ready to see
your very first time i am i'm so excited
oh my gosh let's see it
oh my gosh
christine
[Applause]
i love it it is gorgeous i'm so honored
it is absolutely beautiful
and and way more than i ever expected
and it means so much to have
my children's initials on you know as
art
and i'm so grateful thank you so very
much
it's absolutely beautiful
oh my gosh this has been a dream it's a
dream come true for me
oh my gosh this is a dream come true for
me too
okay i'll show mine as well i'll show
you mine if you show me yours
all right i'm ready for a big reveal
let's see
there it is
home is where we are and wherever life
takes you if you are lucky enough to be
alongside of people you love then to me
that became the definition of home
so thank you for putting
this most important life lesson
um on my arm permanently no it's it's my
honor
and my pleasure and i i couldn't be
happier about the whole experience thank
you so much
thank you um and to my daughters if you
ever get to see this episode
you are my home and i love you more than
anything you're the reason
i understand my whole life because of
you so thank you
you are my home
[Music]